[Applaudissements]
l'allemagne ça fait longtemps colère
folle dérive qu'on nous l'avait réclamé
et jus dance dance port aventura
alors il se lance dans le bras d'eric
transport russes datant il arrive vous
connaissez d'eric non l'inspecteur
derrick
le truc la série suit pourquoi ouais
ouais ouais ça faisait maintenant
regarde le bas vous allez regarder là
vous allez voir c'est notre d'eric un
camarade eric un peu perso ouais donc là
il part dans le game quoi franchement il
y va à fond ces partis regarder
[Musique]
pas possible cette dont bull à un mambo
des risques c'est quoi cette musique la
mixtape me manquera rouillard fragonard
et ouais rico si il veut faire les tubes
planétaires choper des biatch avoir un
appartement à miami
on s'est su prendre comme investisseur
tout magicien j'ai déjà mon honneur au
snuc donc libéré nous après tout bas je
trouve pas ça déglingo qui s'y connaît
aura pas t'asseoir mais je suis super
beau hip hop je danse le mia regarde je
danse le mia pas de pas de tir
chemise ouverte chaîne en or qui brille
d'un coup t'as pas mention engrange même
un j'ai hâte d'entendre tons sont issus
des quartiers défavorisés un des rôles
et keith urban
c'est de la bombe bébé aux oies tip top
top à autre chose autour du scar seul et
u13 et patchwork qui teste sa tante
jaloux bas où l art mikit a certes elles
sont
et attention ça c'est un tube un ghetto
vinet alors c'est super faut aller voir
un producteur oui mais d'abord faut que
j'aille m j'ai commencé à travailler sur
les visuels de ton prochain album pour
dire ce que ça donne à herbiers
prévenait tout la west coast un derrick
arrive pour casser des boules à los
angeles
ils sont combien j'imagine déjà un
carton
belga
afin qu'elles sont
bonne lecture jeudi dernier j'ai eu
droit de la brouille avant
c'est sûr comment maquettes et tu la
mène directement à joey starr la corse
est un ami juste hors jeu sans moyens je
dis à mes questions vous tue sans
déconner je les dis que c'était un ami
je coupe un peu plus tôt j'étais capable
et bizarre le site aucunement de leçon
et qu'il est qu il aime pas les pizzas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
voit ce qu'on s'en sorte remis avec toi
il faut aller voir de remerciement
pouponner